joe tranter is one of thousands of
teenagers with down syndrome having to
shield during the second lockdown
what's the first thing you want to do
when you get back to college more
writing
and you'll be able to get back into the
class see your friends and do more
writing
yeah joe didn't have to shield during
the first lockdown
but this time around the government
placed people with down syndrome
on the clinically extremely vulnerable
list his college
said he could only attend if his mum got
a doctor's note
i was shocked because up until that
point we'd never there was no indication
that they were more vulnerable than
anybody else in the general population
so i ran the doctor on monday then to
sort out the letter what did the doctor
say i didn't speak to the doctor i spoke
to a secretary who said
that um if they do a letter it would
cost 38 pounds
and it will take up to four weeks to
produce
i don't think it's right in this case to
charge the department of health and
social care told us that the clinically
vulnerable haven't
been asked to shield but to be careful
to follow the rules
according to latest research people with
down syndrome
are at greater risk from covid but it's
mainly those
over 40. this has led to some charities
to question whether the guidance is too
broad
and open to misinterpretation they say
if younger people
aren't at as much risk then why are they
put in the same category as those who
are older than them
just because they have down syndrome in
common the whole thing is
is a is a bit of a mess i have to say
carol boys is from the down syndrome
association
people have down syndrome have been told
that they are in this
group that are clinically extremely
vulnerable
and they have to stop doing everything
that they would normally be doing
and stay at home and that
has caused all kinds of upset and
anxiety
that's fishy coat come here but there
are some families who've been shielding
for months now
by choice you're going to get a job in
the amazon rainforest don't you mind
hey destroying trees martin o'neill is
35 and has down syndrome
he hasn't been to his day center since
march his dad jimmy
scared he'll catch the virus how
important is the center in his life
normally
it's probably about 75 of his life going
there
you know i know he's got us but if you
want to
if you ever seen him getting ready for
the censor he hops on the spot
you know jumps about not your martin
hey and without it and he's
he's quieter for those in martin's
position
there is one hope and that's a vaccine
without the vaccine i can't see us doing
another 12 months of this
it's uh it's soul destroying there are
more than two million people
shielding during this pandemic they're
waiting for a time
when their world can open up again
nick martin sky news manchester